IT'S TIME FOR OUR NEXT GAME,
THUG LIFE RAP SHEET.
>> YEAH.
>> HARDWICK: YES.
THE INTERNET IS FULL OF BOLD
SELFIE TAKERS WHO MAY NOT HAVE
BENTLEYS AND CRISTAL, BUT WHO
STILL TRY TO LIVE THAT THUG
LIFE, SO I'M GONNA SHOW YOU A
SELFIE THAT TRIES TO PROJECT AN
AIR OF BALLERNESS, AND FOR 250
POINTS YOU'RE GONNA GIVE US ONE
OF THE CRIMES YOU'D FIND ON
THEIR RAP SHEET, ALL RIGHT?
FIRST UP, THIS HARD-ASS.
(BELL DINGS)
JEFF.
>> THIS GUY WAS ARRESTED FOR,
UH, BREAKFASTING AND ENTERING.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
POINTS.
NEXT ONE: THIS INCONTINENT G.
>> YEAH.
>> HARDWICK: OH, MY GOD.
(BELL DINGS)
MONEY IN A DIAPER SHOULD NEVER
HAPPEN.
JEFF.
>> HE WAS ARRESTED FOR PUTTING
HIS MONEY WHERE HIS MOUTH IS.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
POINTS.
AND FINALLY, GO AHEAD AND TAKE
YOUR SHOTS AT THIS
UN-BELIEB-ABLE ARCHER.
OH, MAN.
(BELL DINGS)
LOCKED AND LOADED, JEFF ROSS.
>> HE'S SHOOTING HIS NEW DOG.
>> I JUST LIKE THAT JOKE 'CAUSE
IT MAKES THE PETA PEOPLE MAD AND
THE JUSTIN BIEBER FANS.
THAT'S, LIKE, A CROSS SECTION.
>> HARDWICK: YEAH, POINTS TO
JEFF ROSS.
UH, NATASHA.
>> UH, HE WAS ARRESTED FOR
BREAKING AND ENTERING BUTTHOLES.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.